this meeting of the international
justice commission is now called to
order
please state your name and call sign for
the record acting commander vivian chase
call sign sojourn
how did you come to join overwatch
my unit of the canadian special forces
teamed up with overwatch during the
omnic crisis
jack morrison and i worked well together
and after the war he reached out
can you give us some examples of duties
you performed
whatever was needed
sometimes i ran point for our agents in
the field
other times i commanded the operation
no matter what their mission was
mine
was to bring every last one of them home
it sounds like you hoped for the
impossible
i know
but they gave me the impossible every
single day
it was the honor of a lifetime to have
served with overwatch
but you can love a thing with your whole
heart and still know it's time to say
goodbye
even the best journeys end
but a new one is right around the corner
and you never know where that road is
gonna take you
[Music]
you